regime
is
him
in the name of Allah the gracious the merciful all praise is due to Allah the
lord of the universe the master of the day of judgment I bear witness and testimony
to the Oneness of Allah to his magnificence his omnipotence his might his glory to his
being the Creator and sustainer of all things The Giver of Life the god of Hearts
the master of the day of judgment and I bear witness to the fact that
muhammadullah
is his servant and final messenger May the peace and blessings of Allah be upon him
and upon all those who Choose To Tread his path until the last day
says in its second verse
that after an initial verse of recognizing how elevated and Sovereign the Divine is he gives
the depiction of himself that says he is the one that has made both death and
life so that we might be from amongst those who seek to perform meet with ibdala
overcome the performance of doing Deeds actions that are good that are better the grammar of
this verse is something that's really important to understand especially within a lot of what we
expose ourselves today in a prism of modernity then when it says it doesn't say that
you have to be the best but the utilization of Assan denotes not the best but
better and ayukum is giving an indication of you all but not in a mode of
competition that it is I versus you in a way that renders an unhealthy sense of
self but the eye that is me today is not afraid to meet the one that
I can come tomorrow
is growth mindset resilience perseverance this is really hard to be the one who is the
best at anything and Islam is a religion doesn't posit itself upon an idea of a
foolish pursuit of perfection it doesn't have this notion that says that our successes are rooted
in that we are better than anyone denoting that we are the first in that way
but then I go in a constant mode of gradual progression that I'm willing to embrace
a notion that I can have change that doesn't have to be rooted in false senses
of self and introspection that is damaging but a sense of self that recognizes that what
it is that I seek to achieve both inwardly and outwardly just has me with me
and not necessarily in comparison to anybody else I want you to think about the way
that most of the world is structured the way that we pit ourselves against one another
in pursuit of things that we are then told will give us a sense of satisfaction
but quite honestly cause more anxiety than anything else the idea that I have to be
able to somehow prove myself to an array of bullet points on a single sheet of
paper in front of an individual that's going to ask me questions that have nothing to
do with me but still nonetheless will have me be positioned against hundreds of others that
I'll never meet in my life to be able to determine that somehow I am the
one that's deserving of whatever it is that they are telling me I need to chase
after of the Dunya that's causing me anxiety in the first place I sit in such
a mode in a bubble day in and day out that has me chip away at
my sense of self-esteem and self-confidence the idea that I pursue what I pursue is not
rooted in what it is that it claims that it gives me anything of real meaning
you don't chase after the money you chase after because you believe that the money is
going to somehow give you a sense of goodness you chase after money that you chase
after because you believe that if you don't have it that means you are not a
good person you chase after a home you desire companionship you want to have certain things
that fall into a formulated process of success because cognitively you have a core belief that
says my goodness is attached to having these things in my hand yet a prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam who slept on a mat that left marks on his back that when his
companions looked around in his home he didn't really have too much of things in terms
of worldly possessions and it would bring tears to their eyes when they would see him
in this way and when he would inquire as to why the tears were there
they would say that the kings of the Romans the Persians they live with such luxury
and comfort they had a love for The Messengers they didn't want to see him exist
in this way but he understood the proportionality of this world in relation to the next
and what he was chasing after wasn't somebody else's aspirations he knew what he believed in
and he knew what he had to do not only to get himself there but to
try to get the people around him that he loved to get there as well if
you were to look at fundamental Game Theory it posits two types of games that come
into existence a game that is considered to be finite in its nature in a game
that's considered to be infinite and many of you probably know this much better than I
do but you want to be able to draw parallels to it from the standpoint of
our spiritual tradition to not think about it just in terms of the way various prisons
of Academia highlighted to us in terms of business corporate sectors in terms of how nation
states interact with each other at times of War any other Industries but to understand it
in terms of the application of yourself and what it is that you're in pursuit of
and how it is that you live for something that does not have necessary a finiteness
to it because you and I we are created beings but we were made for Eternal
existence may Allah make us all people of Jannah and so the idea is that you
don't have to live in a bubble or a box that you're most definitely bigger than
to be able to tell yourself that your goodness is only achieved when you have things
that a lot of the people in the world don't actually have those things they still
have contentment they still have balance and there's a lot of people who do have those
things but it's not the source of their contentment and the ways that we might think
that it's the source of their contentment a finite game is one that is defined as
something that has allocated rules to it one of the best examples that you can utilize
whether you are somebody who is into it or not is to just think about any
professional sport or any level of athletic Endeavor whether it's from Elementary Middle High School Collegiate
or professional that would give you an indication of how this part of it actually functions
if I was to play a basketball game there's five people against five people there's a
set amount of time there's rules there's injunctions that if you don't follow them you will
be fouled in some capacity and at the end of it when time is done somebody
has clearly won and somebody is clearly
lost
that's the way we see the world quite often that there's somehow just a written process
and that I have this very short-sighted perspective on how things function I create rules for
myself that are based in what that if I have money it means I will be
happy and then I'll do whatever it is that I need in order to take it
even if it means somebody else has to have less than is the base minimum of
what someone requires an infinite game in comparison is one that is not played to render
a Victor as such for somebody to be deemed number one it's not one that recognizes
that all players in the game are identified but it understands that there are unknown individuals
that will come into play it's not something that has a designated time period but it
knows that there are things that will continue and the idea is to not just simply
win and move on to the next competition where you win but the idea is to
be able to sustain yourself to be able to be a part of the process that
you don't exist in such a way where you render competition in this unhealthy mode that
says my existence is simply to compare myself to everybody else
but I'm able to just keep going and let people be who they are and let
me be who I am and not be afraid to be the person that I can
become tomorrow did I allow for myself to go in such a mode of existence that
knows that I don't have control over everything that I am not the one that shapes
whatever industry that I'm a part of but I can sit and think about what it
is that I actively contribute to it we have everybody come up close again please if
you can move up there's going to be still a lot of people trickling in and
this is what this verse is telling us
that Allah is the one that is created death and life he is the one that
is able to make things from nothing but the premise that is there and attaching it
to actions and deeds is to give us an Insight that the culmination of Acts is
not just its performance in a worldly sense but there's gonna come a Hereafter an eternal
existence literally a place that is infinite in the way that it goes you can't fathom
forever because you've not experienced it but it's there
and the notion is that you were just trying to do the best of what you
can do that's why the grammar says better and it doesn't designate that there's going to
be one person who gets it right all of the time always
introspection is not real ways and things that are health can have false senses of self
that are rooted in delusional understandings of the self a society that constantly tells you to
compare yourself to other people what does it do to you a false sense of grandeur
that renders a superiority that is not healthy that is rooted in a comparison that says
I'm better than every other person around me may Allah protect us from this arrogance you
are beautiful but it doesn't mean that the people around you are also not beautiful that
you have strengths and others have strengths there is goodness to you and there is goodness
in others the other end of the spectrum is a introspection that is rooted in and
alternating reality of the self an inferiority introspection one that is rooted in a delusional sense
of insignificance there's nothing good in me everybody is better than me I have nothing to
offer I don't deserve to be where I'm sitting right now how did I end up
in this place it's a comparison that again is rooted in a mindset of how do
I relate to those that are around me when our tradition is rooted is neither of
these delusional senses of self but is more about an introspection that is interiority that you
are just looking within and that you are not afraid to take a gander at what
it is that you have going on in the world inside of you to take moments
to rest to be able to understand that the output and productivity that comes from the
ability to have Deeds that are qualified in a mode of person Beauty is rooted in
the inward components to the performance of them not just the action itself why do you
chase after the things you chase after do you ever really think about it ever get
to a place where you can assess for yourself what does real goodness mean to me
that degree that you got that's amazing you don't have to undermine it that job that
you have that's a beautiful thing also not a problem it's not what makes you good
though it's not where you want to only render Improvement if you've ever gone into a
bookstore which you'd be surprised how many people do not go into bookstores anymore and if
you don't you should reading is a good thing you can find
comparative modes of existence they have us engage in a genre that can be something that
is quite beneficial but you want to think about its presence in relation to the absence
of things there are thousands of self-help books written each and every day how do I
become better at X Y or Z there's no bookstore that has a section that teaches
you how to help other people there's no text that are written that you can pick
up and there's an entire section allocated within that store that says this is how you
can go and be a source of light for somebody else this is how you take
that skill this is how you take that degree this is how you take that wealth
this is how you take that Network this is how you take everything that you have
accrued and then you go and be a means of Hope for others never the reason
that somebody might dread it but in a place now where a world wants us to
ourselves in an anxiety that there's always something that is not good within you you got
to remember what Allah tells you know that he has made Humanity in the most beautiful
of forms so your default setting is that you are a creature of beauty you do
have goodness there is light to you there is Luminosity to you and the way to
uphold that is to not gaze to yourself in a perspective that then causes you to
be stifled to put your Reliance and Trust on things that are not meant to be
what are true enhancements of Who You Are but to be able to recognize that regardless
of where you might be in whatever positionality of this world and what it deems to
be successful your goodness is rooted and not necessarily just doing what others say is what
has to be done to be successful but you take it from someplace else that allows
for you to not be afraid to reach your actual potential you have a prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam who beyond anything else was just a good person
and when you think about everyone and anyone who in the coming weeks around the world
is going to be in this month of sitting in Gatherings remembering who Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was
his leadership wasn't something that was given to him because of a rank that's not
leadership
his authority wasn't something that was defined just because he went through a upward mobile hierarchy
that just designated power to him his life was not just in pursuit of seeking validation
of who it was that he was but he allowed for himself to know who he
was by being in a place where he was comfortable with others being who they were
as well if you don't take a pause to sometimes sit and think about what does
it all mean and what is it that you are seeking and how the idea is
to not engage in actions that are at a face value self-serving but in reality not
serving the self but they're just chipping away at your sense of confidence your self of
sense of self-esteem
and you take from a man sallallahu alaihi wasallam who was of balance of contentment who
had difficulty who had tragedy who buried most of his children alive outlived them what a
hard thing to experience who's impacted at the loss of his wife and his uncle Abu
Talib so much so that the historians of the prophetic biography deemed that year after those
tragedies take place to be a year of grief a year of depression because of what
it did to our Messengers
he wasn't doing what he did to win he wasn't doing what he did because he
was in competition with anybody else he wasn't doing what he did because he wanted to
say that I am the best I am number one he was just doing what he
did because he knew it was the right thing to do he was moving forward on
the trajectory that he moved forward upon and encourage others to move forward in that way
as well so that they didn't have to be Shackled by some of what it was
that confined so many of us even till today in terms of deeming for ourselves what
goodness actually is why are you not a good person if you are unmarried why are
you not a good person if you don't get into med school may Allah make all
of you who are studying to be doctors again into med school I want to deal
with your parents yelling at me let them yell at you but why are you a
bad person why are you not a good person if you don't have children you don't
have a house and the other end of that question is important to ask yourself why
did having those things make you good to the extent then that they create a metric
of assessment to say that somebody who does not have it that means that I'm somehow
better than they are the distinguishing factor in our tradition is not any of these things
it's just how you use your time the acts that you put into this world the
light that you are sharing with others the goodness that you give of yourself that's what
it comes down to if you are Elder in this room and not Elder in the
sense that you started coming here when you were much younger and you still think in
your head that you are that young you're not you have a responsibility to turn to
the younger people who are inheriting a world that is so deeply Laden in a technology
that has kept them from understanding how to actually interact with others in meaningful ways that
you can shake them out of it and say that hey it's okay for you to
actually go and be confident in yourself
you don't need to be the person standing on this side of the Jamal to be
able to tell people in sight all of you have something to teach and you turn
to somebody who is inherited now something that they never asked for a world that was
distinct from where you were when you were growing up we had a young man in
our community a student Just A Week Ago by the name of shahir who got into
a car accident that was quite difficult Ella Grant and ease in shafa and we're going
to be raising some funds to help him get through what it is and we'll share
that with you over the weekend and I know that this community is going to step
up the way that we always step up to help those when they need our support
especially when it's one of our own
when we were aware of what happened to him
his car had smoke coming from the back and then Flames started to light up oh
he was driving through streets of New Jersey that were not well lit and the car
lost control and he went down a cliff it then rolled over multiple times until it
somehow subhanallah landed on the wheels he got out of it and sought to put the
water out in his own story he said that that car was his Elder Brothers who
subhanallah had passed away two years before and it meant so much to their family in
terms of its sentimental value we couldn't put the fire out Flames just
and then he had to go to the hospital because he got burned from the fire
Mela Grant him he's
and we made to offer him people expressed whatever they did over various text messages and
WhatsApp groups and then I went to see him and there was four young men from
this community who also came to see me with him and why I share this with
you is because going forward there should be an endless line of people that want to
go and see somebody when they're in that situation and I'm not faulting anybody because when
I say I sat down with others who over the course of however many of the
last not just weeks or months of years said that my friends know that this person
died in my family my friends know that this person is sick in the hospital my
friends know that these things are going on why is it that they're not asking me
about it why aren't they checking in on me why aren't they reaching out to me
I'm gonna tell you that one of the reasons not the only reason is that nobody
has ever taught you how to do it
but this is the time that you remember who your teacher is who you take instructions
from is not the time to leave people by themselves it's not the time to justify
an absence of being able to engage people right literally our tradition teaches us
that the visiting of the sick is a right that a Muslim has on a Muslim
where did it get lost
in the midst of the pursuit of some worldly sense of success that teaches you to
either hate yourself or hate others and take whatever dollar you can regardless of where it
is you're taking it from of the many consequences of that or that people that need
us are getting left behind
so if you're an elder person in this room you turn to a younger person and
you recognize that most of what it is that they're taking their lessons from are a
piece of Hardware that exists in their hand that just gives them information in 10 second
sound bites nobody's saying to them this is how you are a good person this is
how you engage a world that quite heavily is filled with heaviness this is how you
go and greet those that you know and those that you don't know this is how
you fill the world with Deeds that are has seen each one of you has something
to teach somebody and each one of you has something that you can learn as well
that change has to come from within you start with a default understanding of yourself that
you deserve where you are to be there are no mistakes and no absence of meanings
in God's plan he created you with a purpose and it wasn't to just be in
pursuit of things that give you a false sense of fulfillment and once you can recognize
what it is that you are made of and what it is that you are built
upon you're going to be able to go and do things that you couldn't even imagine
that don't have to be at levels of grandeur you don't have to build buildings or
build companies or build this or build that but even if you're impacting one heart in
a positive way you're able to give somebody a sense of upliftment a sense of hope
that might be everything that somebody needs to make their entire Journey forward feel something different
so on this day of jummah look within yourself in a productive way to Allah that
you stop seeing yourself in terms of where you are lacking or seeing others in terms
of where you perceive them to be deficient ask Allah to help you to see yourself
the way that he sees you as zojan to be able to see you at the
level of your heart and everything that you have capacity to be able to give and
it's going to make all of the difference in terms of what it is that you
are able to experience when you move through this world until you get to a place
of ultimate contentment in the world Beyond this run
thank
you
one of the secrets of contentment is just service of others that's truth you just gotta
decide what you're going to do with it and so you make commitment that you actually
become part of something that makes you want to sacrifice for the sake of its success
that you're willing to give up time to inconvenience yourself because you're working towards something that's
bigger the benefit that can be rendered through you as well as the benefit that you
will gain from it is something that will be undeniable today after the jummah prayer there's
a brother who's going to be taking his shahada so if you can be a part
of that inshallah we're also going to have lunch for the community and anything uh that
you're able to uh offer during that time as I said in the first part go
find people that you've never met before talk to them not just the people you know
look for those who are sitting by themselves or those that you could engage if you're
a younger person and somebody older comes to talk to you don't be creeped out unless
they're being creepy then let me know though we benefit from a community not by just
being individuals sitting in a room together and despite being in close proximity still being separate
we only benefit from a community where we in meaningful ways are able to come together
and what sometimes separates us is not somebody else's treatment of us but how we see
and treat ourselves we can't benefit from the blessing that is uniquely you if you don't
think you actually have something to offer and you break that down by removing that problematic
prism that this world seeks to impose upon you that says that you're in a fight
with everybody else to somehow get to some place of victory that at the end of
the day when you get there it's just the next thing you got to take on
as well so just do what it is that you're able to do that's what Allah
wants from each one of us we have a God that looks for a reason to
accept from us not look for a reason to push us away
We Begin this supplication in your name Ya Allah we beseech you to send your choices
salutations upon your most beloved sallallah we ask that you shower your infinite mercy upon this
Gathering granting each and everyone who is present herein in our loved ones only the best
in this world and the best in the next we ask Ya Allah that if all
of us are meant to be together only at this time at this place whether we
are young or old male or female regardless of our race our ethnicity our social class
our country of origin our cultural heritage whether we are Muslim or come from a different
Walk of Life if our individual hearts are meant to be in the presence of all
of their hearts that are gathered here only at this time at this place then gather
us all together again in the best of places in the world Beyond this one increases
Ya Allah in all that is good increases encourage compassion and confidence protect us from Affliction
anxiety and anguish remove from our hearts any feelings of bitterness jealousy animosity or Envy towards
any of your creation greatest hearts that are filled with understanding and hope hearts that are
drawn towards things of real goodness and Beauty hearts that find themselves deep in your remembrance
for indeed in your remembrance do hearts find rest we ask Allah that for all those
who are facing any Affliction difficulty in our community and beyond that you send to them
the best of supporters and helpers and make us a means of benefit for your creation
we ask y'allah that for those who are longing for friendship companionship of any kind that
you send to them those who will be from amongst the best of their friends and
companions that you arrange their hearts with hearts that are gentle and tender and you give
them a bond that exists throughout every day in this world leading them to a place
together in the best of places in the world Beyond this one we ask Ya Allah
that for all those who are in a place where the openings come and they have
the opportunity to choose what is good and right that you make us always those who
choose what is good and right that we think before we Act that you make us
those who make decisions through our hearts and never at their expense and that when we
make mistakes and we forget grant us that ofik to understand that we can always turn
back to you that you are there for us closer to us than our own jugular
veins make us those who recognize and feel the presence of your mercy your love every
day that we Traverse through this world protect us always from hearts that are not humble
tongues that are not wise and eyes that have forgotten how to cry forgive us for
our shortcomings and guide and bless us all right